on a préparé un petit jeu vous allez
jouer si vous êtes d'accord avec jean
michel
alors je vais vous demander à tous les
deux d'avoir la gentillesse de bien
vouloir venir là vous allez voir y'a
rien de grave au rien d'incroyable alors
j'explique les règles nous allons aux
clichés sur le barco cinq phrases mais
on les affiches en indonésien
oui vous allez d'ailleurs nous les lire
et il va choisir de 1 à 5 une des
phrases les voilà ce que vous voulez
bien vous voulez lire la première la
première un goon à kamenar ibla mc amour
la deuxième un gone accompagné du
cameroun du ghana et ce bateau à la
troisième voilà comme un brigand au
minimum
quatrième à murakami bricout et paquets
crime est d'accord la saq est 5e en a
quand même qui hument carmaux voilà de
renom jean michel va choisir une de ces
phases une action derrière alors ça peut
être des trucs très sympa ça peut être
anggun va danser avec toi ça peut être
en goût ne vas te faire un bisou ça peut
être aussi un goon va-t-on tarte et donc
à mon bien
bien choisir par contre elle va vous le
redire une fois une fois vous aurez
choisie vous pouvez choisir un autre
chroniqueur si vous le sentez pas je
sens bien
relisez-les à celle que vous sentez
angola can en dessous qu'en monoplace à
carmaux oui alors donnons-lui roddick
nordiques et la france on regardera les
yeux angola can win tin can oui oui
c'est dako qu'il arrive
est ce que vous faites cette phrase est
ce que vous la donner à quelqu'un
d'autre ce défi panneaux non ne dites
pas demandez pas son avis en même temps
et peut-être pas envie mon bras c'est ça
qui fait une tête et rappelez-vous d'un
truc
l'émission a une fin i
[Applaudissements]
regardez ça va changer changer à
l'étranger je change ma là un bon voilà
là hein vous la faites vous vous le
donner à quelqu'un
pas moi bah si je tombe sur embrasser je
pardonne et d'attirer les moyens je suis
au regret non nous avons ces six celle à
50 jours ogün aken gennari barça macabou
cela veut dire en français qu un good
bad danser avec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le 3 le 3 au goût à se prononce un gars
comme beckham aux minimes en place la
[ __ ] s'attendre à pédalage attention
je donne à thierry moreau thierry moreau
vous venez ici
donc là on ne voit pas lucre à dire on
va lui faire qu'est ce qu'il a bisous eh
bien regardez les avoir à les y buvait
le car ça voulait dire rangoon va offrir
une boisson pimenté allait accuser un
coup sec
[Musique]
non c'est impossible
[Applaudissements]
j'ai des origines
la can la 4s que un goût n'a qu'à la
mairie ou et paquets crime pas pkra tant
que crime écrit que gm il a cinq ou six
ouais ouais pas qu'à eric arthur erika
modérée qu'ailleurs
mettez vous bien autour de la table a
donc erika à votre avis je sens dans les
yeux d'un coup qu'on va pas s'embrasser
parce que ça nous aurait tous eu aussi
j'aurais bien aimé le faire on good si
vous voulez le gone pas quartier à
kanombe coup et paca crime voulais dire
à 20
vous pouvez aller
mardi à faune et les moutons en lozère
les attentions
ouais
serviette
je vais prendre l'a5 que je vais donner
à la neige
ouais
[Applaudissements]
et
donc vous prenez le 2 alors puisque
synode est chauffé les 5 vous prenez le
2 donc on va tout de suite j'ai changé
non c'est fini
si j'ai pris la 5 au début on m'avait
dit il fallait pas le prendre alors
qu'est-ce que vous prenez la saint-jean
mis la 5
c'était mon premier choix au départ les
pieds vous donner le 2e à qui n'émeut
dramé de change et la neige mais n'a ici
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'on te cogner une coupe ça sera
bien ça pour le même mois la mort
le petit bisou attention le petit parce
que c'est un tout petit bisou c'est
aussi des basques en fait ouinch heyy
ououm ça vaut pas être dire sur la boue
annonce banon ben oui mais là c'est
gênant aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois que je peux vous savez ma vie
du coup à jouer
[Applaudissements]